foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello hello everybody Welcome to daily
with Doc my name is Becca dukes and if
my co-host could open up the doors and
let those that are here waiting to be
live with us because we do do this show
live and you if you are out on one of
the platforms or even watching a replay
you are personally invited to join us
here on daily with Doc so we run this
program most Mondays through Fridays
from 12 to 12 50 p.m Pacific time and
it's super super simple to join us
in your URL address bar not the Google
search sure the Safari search but in the
address bar type in Daily with Doc
zoom.com all one word daily with Doc
zoom.com
and you will be able to come right over
into our waiting room where we will let
you in during the time of the show so if
you're there and you're sitting there
wondering
how come I'm not being let in well we
open the doors and close the doors at
the time of the show so just hang out or
join us back during this time 12 to 12
50 p.m Pacific time this program is
being sponsored by dailywithdoc.com we
are a group of independent Associates
who are coaches with a passion for
helping people find a better health
Journey
my name is Becca dukes and as the leader
of this group of uh coaches I am also
the director of student services for The
Institute of holistic health where we
train people on the four areas of Health
how they're affected by nutritional
deficiencies and then use a line of
product that we have found to be
solutions for correcting those
deficiencies if you would like more
information about becoming a certified
holistic health coach get with the
person that shared this program with you
if there's nobody to think go to
coachwithdoc.com that is
coachwithdoc.com now
in this program we do have to let you
know that this program is for
educational purposes only on the
importance of intentional nutritional
supplementation folks our food is null
and void of the nutrition that our body
actually needs to be Beyond just
surviving we are all about thriving and
it is very possible when you are
intentional about what you do and don't
put in your mouth now
this program is not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician nor
are the products meant to treat diagnose
or cure any different condition or
disease but folks
the man that we have with us during this
time is one of the founding fathers of a
science called epigenetics if you've
never heard of epigenetics and you've
been told that you have a genetic
condition well
I'm hoping that you find like I did the
hope that this science of epigenetics
brings because epigenetics has proven
the theory of disease transmission
through genetics to be incorrect
that means that even if we so-called
have these conditions that our mother
and our grandmother and our father and
grandfather have or had
we don't have to be stuck with them
now there are birth defects that are
caused by nutritional deficiencies
and you're going to hear more about
those today I I absolutely know it
because that's one of his this doctor's
passions is to help those babies come
into this world as healthier individuals
so that they can live full long lives
if I can get Dr Wallach to join me here
on the screen
Dr Wallach welcome to daily stock
so I know today we're going to be
talking about hard tissue
which is one and we're just going to be
touching on it but that's one of the
four areas of Health that we teach about
at the Institute of holistic health and
the majority of our research which has
been supported many times
by resources since
um
just proves that what you
found
is correct
and I have Joe out on YouTube saying not
meant to cure but it sure fixed my
issues so and I'm with you Joe
I mean Dr Wallach
your your research and the formulas that
you are instrumental in putting together
have helped a lot of people
so tell us about hard tissue and what
causes hard tissue what is hard tissue
what causes the hard tissue decline
and then what are some solutions
okay well hard tissue we're talking
about bones uh we're talking about
cartilage tendons ligaments those kind
of things everything to do with your
skeleton and joints are a little more
complicated than the bone the bone is
primarily bone we're adjointed as
bone-in cartilage and tendons and
ligaments those joints a little more
complicated and
it's one of those things where I saw a
lot of that so when I was a little kid
my father was a champion boxer
um with the uh uh
but the
was he lightweight heavyweight
welterweight
yeah he he was he was a bantamweight
abandonment lesson lesson lightweight
okay and
um this
and of course we would go to the gym
every day I'm only three four years old
we go to the gym and see all these guys
of big guys heavyweights and
middleweights and lightweights and
bandweights like my dad
and um
they would be working out on the hitting
the bags and running and lifting weights
and stuff like that climbing on on um
ropes to
get different muscles involved
and so I I grew up
in a system by which everybody I saw was
either throwing bales of hay onto the
wagons or off the wagons or at the gym
okay
um working out the gym and so exercise
and work
um exercise that was very very common to
me okay
um to make a long story short
the
um cost just to treat the symptoms of
um arthritis the United States which
is we're talking about joints
is 626.8 billion dollars
626.8 billion dollars
okay when you look at all the common
diseases we deal with
is the most expensive
disease arthritis except for
osteoporosis osteoporosis when you look
at
osteoporosis which is the bones
primarily and usually doesn't include
does not include the joints osteoporosis
in America is 2.3 trillion dollars
and that's just to treat the symptoms
and when you take three
um
communities United States Canada and the
EU European Union we spend 6.5 trillion
dollars a year just to treat the
symptoms of osteoporosis not to
preventative cure
this is very scary stuff okay because
very simple nutritional deficiency
diseases repeat that they're just simple
nutritional diseases and we're paying
all this money just to treat nutritional
symptoms nutritional deficiency diseases
whenever we just take supplements
okay like we give our animals and we so
we give them supplements for animals
when I was nine years old I was going to
be hospitalized because I had all kinds
of
um behavioral problems and physical
problems for the so forth and I just
started eating
um animal Foods who are super saturated
with supplemental vitamins and minerals
and I cured myself in three days
I didn't have to get institutionalized
so I realized that
um the reason why we don't have health
insurance
for Animals is because we're putting all
these vitamins and minerals into their
food
and says why don't we do that for humans
well the doctors they just eat
everything and you know just eat well
and get everything you need well
that may have been partially true
many years ago but certainly not true at
all now I say partially true some years
ago you have to appreciate you go back 3
000 years ago in the Old Testament
people knew that people live longer and
were healthier when they came from
landslowing with milk and honey
okay uh was that cow's milk goat's milk
sheep's milk I mean whose milk was it
well it turns out it wasn't any of that
it was glacial milk the glaciers
grinding up the rocks at the top of the
mountains and when the when the snow and
the glaciers would melt the water would
come down in a stream it looked like
milk coming down the side of the
mountain so that's where they got the
term but they didn't have the ability to
analyze stuff three thousand years ago
and there were all kinds of stories in
the Old Testament 21 stories to deal
with the landform of milk and honey
and we're talking about
over 100 mentions of the land flowing
milk and honey in the Old Testament
Adam lived to be
930 no others would be 950 Methuselah
would be 969 and many many other uh
people who came from these landforms
milk and honey Angels who did God's work
okay and taken the message all around
the world they lived me 800 700 600 okay
and guess what
we look at um the hunzas with Himalayan
mountains are still living in a place
where they get the glacial milk and um
their life expectancy is 120. they don't
have any medical doctors their life
expectancy is 120. we have the finest
medical doctors on Earth just ask them
and our life expectancy depending on
whose numbers you're looking at is 71 to
75.
so what's the difference well the land
flowing of building honey they're
getting all these minerals coming from
the melted
glaciers Bringing Down the rock dust
into their drinking water their
irrigation water and so forth
even make their wine with the irrigation
with this glacial milk okay so they're
getting minerals minerals minerals
minerals that's why they live so long so
without more said about that I do want
to talk more about what we can do now
we know this okay we have some very
famous people
um Phil Ratliff a great great great
basketball player 24 years old he had
bone of arthritis his knees he had bone
and Bone arthritis in his hips he had
fractures and shooting arm wrist his
right hand and so he lost his contract
which was 35 million dollars
and um
the
um I wanted to say one of his buddies in
professional basketball okay
um brought him to me and
um Mike Glenn was the guy's name the
great the Stinger he was called the
stinger and okay the Stinger brought
Theo Ratliff to me and we came up with
what we called the healthy Bone and
Joint pack was our Healthy Start pack
with a 90th Century nutrients in it and
we came up with our first collagen
product it was called glucogel we added
the glucose gel to the healthy brain to
the healthy shark pack and we called it
the healthy Bone and Joint pack
and in three or four months now uh
theoretlive got another contract and he
played for 11 years made over 100
million dollars and I was so very proud
of him he could have taken all that
money and run
but what he did he actually
purchased very large uh land and
building facility okay it was an
activity center
activity center and makes the the
information
free to kids who want to either play
sports or once you get into the
professions like being doctors and
lawyers and that sort of stuff so I
thought it was really really gracious to
him he didn't have to do that but he did
it and so this is the kind of people
we're working with
another a great um
athlete Evander Holyfield great Champion
he had heart issues and couldn't answer
the bill for his final round in
protecting his Heavyweight Championship
so he lost his Heavyweight Championship
by default so he came up with a healthy
brain and heart fact for him okay and
after just like six months he came back
and just destroyed Mike Tyson who
through a series of events had
um gotten the Payway title and he just
destroyed Mike Tyson Mike Tyson bit his
ears off because he knew he was losing
the match okay and and so this is the
sort of things we do with our programs
okay and right now we have programs for
600 different diseases
um we sold our licenses for
um jewelry and that kind of perfume and
that kind of stuff so we have five we
used to have 5 000 products with the
jewelry and and so forth but now because
we got rid of the jewelry and and um uh
perfume and that kind of stuff we now
have three thousand products okay so
we're very very excited about that and
one of those things where this is much
broader than people think when you can
ask the approaches of the skull
okay it squeezes the 12 pairs of cranial
nerves and the spinal cord you lose your
sense of smell that's cranial nerve
number one you get optic nerve atrophy
and you get
um glaucoma pressure in the eye goes up
uh you get macular degeneration which is
a part of the eye in the back of the eye
where the optic nerve the optic optic
vein come in and out of okay and when
the second trailer gets squeezed they're
Trail nerve you get ptosis pupil doesn't
respond to light fourth trailer gets
squeezed obviously a process is called
your double vision okay and then
trigeminal neuralgia I mean we're
talking about pain trigeminal pain pain
pain that's the cream there everything
squeezed the six round nerve being
squeezed you get double vision it's
called trabismus
and then Bell's Palsy uh one part of
your face will droop one side of your
face with droop that's the seventh
cranial nerve being squeezed okay and
then let's see here maybe a trailer gets
squeezed it has two main branches
um you get tinnitus okay rain in the
ears and deafness which is
self-explanatory and then these vertigo
has a different branch that's a
vestibular branch of the atrial nerve we
get all of them vertigo deafness and
tinnitus it's called Meniere's disease
Maxwell nerve gets squeezed it's a
glossopharyngeal nerve you lose your
sense of taste uh you have a gag reflex
problem and swallowing and all that kind
of stuff your voice changes tensorial
nerve gets squeezed it's called
gastroparesis that really is bad okay
causes irregular heartbeat you get fast
heart rate tachycardia Soul heart rate
bradycardia and then you get irregular
heart rate atrial fibrillation and
doctors think it's a heart issue no afib
is not a heart issue it's actually due
to squeezing of the 10th cranial nerve
okay by the skull
and
there's many many other issues that go
along with squeezing the 10th parameter
and we don't have time to get into all
of them
um but it's in the book it's all in your
head okay you need to get the book on
your head each there's a chapter for
each of these cranlers and all the
diseases and symptoms you get when they
get squeezed okay and they're all
reversible it's all fixable uh cranial
nerve number 11 loss of trapezius
function you can't lift your arms above
your head uh that's the 11th cranial
nerve the 12th cranial nerve atrophy of
the tongue speech swallowing again so
you get trim nerve number nine and
twelve being squeezed you're really in
trouble
and then when a baby is born without she
approaches the skull her bar with
osteoposis go they get herbs Falls
they're paralyzed from the neck down
okay and then we call this whole thing
velocity approaches to the skull uh
while it Wallace fibrosis okay because
your skull gives me an inch and a half
to two inches a seconds from connective
tissue because the skull is gone
but it's repairable usually then uh you
know I've seen it happen in weeks you're
starting to see Improvement and um we
have all kinds of stuff going on here in
just weeks when you give it the right
thing when you just treat the symptoms
this is a lifetime issue but when you
treat the cause
osteoporosis of the skull guess what
things get better quickly okay I think
with that I'm going to turn this back
over to Rebecca here
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach
um so there's there's so many things
that you have discovered those things
being symptoms that are associated with
hard tissue that that hard or yeah the
hard tissue that heart tissue being
associated with osteoporosis which
osteoporosis is not just in a hip or a
leg or the hands but osteoporosis of the
skull folks
I mean if you can get osteoporosis in
any other area of the body why not the
skull it's a bone too
right doc that's correct that's why we
came up with a book because doctors are
not taught doctors are still today not
talk uh talked about obviously processor
skull they think osteoporosis just
occurs from the neck down
okay and um we're talking about you know
you throw in osteoporosis to the skull
okay and then you have other soft tissue
things that go along with it that are
all caused by the deficiency of a single
nutrient
okay we're talking about Alzheimer's
disease MS Embry syndrome Parkinson's
disease funnel temporal dementia I had a
call today about
um quite chilled Jacobs disease which is
also known as mad cow disease
ALS Lou Gehrig's disease and you get
those things along with osteoporosis of
the skull you got a mess
okay but they're all fixable and so we
have many many people who have been
repaired with these issues because we
treat the issues as they're supposed to
be treated giving the body what it needs
to maintain and replace the tissues that
went away because they weren't getting
these nutrients in their diets for a
variety of reasons
um sometimes because it just weren't
there sometimes because they're eating
gluten and buckwheat was Bagel Pyrenees
in they couldn't absorb the nutrients
even if they're supplementing so these
are all these various things that go on
there and doctors just say here we'll
take this painkiller
and
that's their
that's what they told me Doc
and they said nothing about diet and I
loved the taste of my buckwheat plant
pancakes
and everything whole grain and ground
ground my own wheat berries I made sure
they were organic and you know all the
things that are quote unquote healthy
yet I was getting sicker and sicker and
I couldn't understand it until I met you
Doc and as sportas says out on YouTube
he says he treated me like a dog but I
did get better so folks if you're kind
of skeptical about
the medical model
because of
experience
or every commercial that you hear every
other commercial that you see on TV is
pushing another drug
there's a reason why you're skeptical
is because there's a better option and
that's what we are sharing today
so thank you so much for joining us here
if you are here live with us in the zoom
room we want to make sure that you know
if you have a question that you would
like to ask go to that Zoom menu click
on reactions and raise your hand like we
have many people who have done so far
already if you have questions
um and you're on any of the platforms I
have an amazing team they're helping to
monitor those different platforms so
that we can get your questions asked and
addressed also and
if you're not able to get on or you want
to have a personal
response or have me read the question
for you or one of my co-hosts you can go
to ourdailywithdoc.com
you want to make sure that you sign up
for our newsletter our newsletter right
now is going out only once a week it is
sharing the replays links to the replays
plus descriptions from previous week
that makes it easier for you to be able
to find information when you do a search
on your on your email but most
importantly share it with somebody else
so that they too can have this
information and then make the decision
as to whether or not they want a better
alternative
so Dr Wallach the first hand that we
have up today
um kind of Falls in with what you were
talking about with some of the symptoms
that I read that this gentleman is
having so Randall if you could please
unmute yourself if you're on live with
Dr Wallach
yes how are you Miss Sherry
so my name is Becca and I'm doing
fantastic
scary
she's one of our co-hosts
outstanding but Doc is here to help you
so how can we help
okay um first I'd like to say uh the 90
for life I think is what my me and my
wife are using it's it's beginning to
help her back she said as she started
using it her back I believe is
I think she said within the first weeks
you could feel it coming up two inches
and um I think making it more limber is
what she's saying and now it's worked
halfway up her back because she's kind
of small she's probably 5'115 and she's
had scoliosis her whole life so I just
want to thank Dr wallet for that and
what he does
um but coming you know finding Dr
Wallach through the internet Mr obrano
here has reached out to me uh you can
see him right here to my right and um
he's his health is spelling him really
bad he's having a hard time uh keeping
anything down he's having diarrhea
really bad I've got probably 10 to 12
medicines right here that that he's
taking and it doesn't matter what he
does
you know what doctor it goes to what um
type of medicine he gets on nothing
seems to help so I want to reach out to
you guys and see what you guys could do
to help him out okay how much does he
weigh
how much you weigh Jerry
I'm sorry I can't hear him
we he's he's really feeble he's probably
about five seven I would guess
maybe 120 to 140.
yeah he says it's not even 120 or 140.
so he he may he said maybe a hundred
pounds right now okay does he have any
other issues like highly pressure
diabetes
you've got high blood pressure diabetes
no sir he said he doesn't
okay at least they haven't told him at
the doctors that he does that's what he
told me does he have any arthritis or
osteoporosis
you got arthritis or osteoporosis
he's kind of his his speech is kind of
low he said no doctors have ever told
him he has either of those issues Dr
wallet okay so here we go
he's getting rid of all the bad stuff
no fried foods no processed Meats no
oils no glutens no wheat by Ryan oats no
buckwheat because of the fago Pyrenees
and buckwheat no sugar no carbonator
drinks you know the diet drinks got to
go in carbonated water because they
neutralize stomach acids so you cannot
absorb minerals or digest food
then
it um let's see here we said what 120
pounds somewhere between 100 and 120
pounds probably yeah he needs one
healthy brain and heart pack per month
the half of those everything twice a day
in these one bottle a month of our MSM
string tape because two breakfast two at
lunch at dinner time that's going to
help them rebuild cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue disc between
invertebrate bone matrix bone itself it
needs the ultimate enzymes I want them
to have the ultimate enzymes he can take
two of those before each meal say five
or ten minutes for each meal uh with a
couple ounces of water I also want him
to have our synaptive
and can get to
um at his weight he could get one bottle
a month and take one or two synaptive
twice a day and then he also needs our
chewable
are chewable
um
I-26 okay it comes in vanilla ice cream
which I use ARC you can use the banana
coconut okay okay okay and
um it will help rebuild the the brain
cells and the spinal cord cells and all
that kind of stuff so everything can
talk to each other
and
so let's go there and it wouldn't hurt
if he's not getting out and sunny
himself a couple of days a week he needs
to get our vitamin D3 capsules also
until go out on the porch some but in
most days he don't really he doesn't get
around a whole lot yeah okay so you need
to take the two or three a day of our
vitamin D3 templates okay
look um by the way I didn't I didn't
think about bringing anything to Ryan
I've got all his medicines here this is
all being recorded okay okay so also
um he needs a rebound or his first
shrink
um uh I like uh we come in sticks
there's 30 sticks in a box has 100
nutrients in here there's 100 nutrients
75 minerals and 25 vitamins middle acids
poured into a bottle of water okay and
uh his body weight he could take one of
those a day take a half of it you know
breakfast and a half at lunchtime okay
and uh that's going to give him another
source of those minerals uh and vitamins
which are going to help him rebuild his
tissues okay
okay let's go let's go from there
polish every couple of weeks
say that again Dr Wallach Paul is every
couple of weeks
it's toll free can call us every couple
weeks it's toll free doesn't caution
anything to call us and tell us
okay yes sir yes sir I'll gladly do that
okay thank you
um by the way how how can I access this
so I can hear what you said I'm gonna
tell you right now Randall and everybody
else that is listening we are live
streaming which we almost immediately
after the live stream ends you can go to
one of the platforms whether you're
watching on Rumble YouTube Instagram
Spotify Amazon
um Amazon
part we have a channel on each of those
including
um patreon
where and Facebook where you do a search
for critical Health news or critical
health or daily with Doc and you will
find us and find all of our replays so I
love the fact that we have those replays
available almost instantly so that
people can go to them listen fast
forward stop replay and write everything
down I know Dr Wallach speaks fast
faster than me
um but having those options are
absolutely essential in helping us to be
able to get what the information we need
so we can put it into action so Randall
thank you so much for coming on and
wanting to help others in your community
this uh one last question
um what about the medicines he's already
taken and if y'all have any advice about
that or
well
um we have to know what they are before
we give any advice and so you don't need
to make a list but to usually if you
have a prescription drug you want to
talk to the doctor about those
okay all right because he's got probably
12 right here in front of me
yeah so Randall if you go to daily
withdoc.com and use that contact option
you can send us an email with that list
for the most part
um folks if you're on a pharmaceutical
and you want to monitor at home whatever
that pharmaceutical is
controlling okay and if there are any
type of food restrictions you definitely
want to take those into account but
definitely work with your primary care
physician they are probably not educated
on the importance of nutrition so they
don't know exactly how they interact or
will react but we still want you to make
sure that you are staying in contact
with your with your doctor so that as
they see the improvements also because
of this initi this intentional nutrition
um it might wake them up to the fact
that hey masking the symptoms are not
the only option here okay so I'm
reaching out to you guys have the answer
I understand that they don't it's a
money-making industry but that's another
conversation itself that's a
conversation all in its own 24-hour
segment sir
so thank you again for coming on
okay thank you man Randall you can find
the list Marilyn posted it in the chat
yes so if you're here live with us make
sure that you have that chat all option
open
because we do have Marilyn who is one of
our co-hosts who is absolutely fantastic
at doing dictation and typing and she
has transcribed what Dr Wallach
mentioned
as the protocol
and put it in the chat so make sure that
you have that chat option open and do a
screenshot or take a picture of it if
you're on the computer have a phone
whatever it is you can get that
information and then take it to the
coach that is that you're working with
if there are is not a coach to thank and
you found us on your own you're more
than welcome to reach out to one of my
team at
855-949-3377 that is
855-949-3377 again they are available
for people who have never spoken to
anybody about Dr Wallach youngevity or
any of the products and have not
purchased products before you can also
go to our daily wood DOC website and use
that contact us option as well let's go
to the next town that is up Dr Wallach
and jinji go ahead and unmute yourself
[Music]
with Doc and I apologize if I didn't
pronounce your right name correctly but
if you said it perfect usually I'm on my
my phone and it says JT so I'm the same
one all right welcome welcome Jen Gingy
doctor
yes how can I help you sir all right so
uh I've got a friend that I'm helping
here and he he loved the idea of the 90
because he was already taking like 80
percent of of what's in the daily you
know the 90 essential nutrients and I
got him hooked up with the digestion
pack and he really didn't like how sweet
it was
um he said he doesn't want to take any
maltodextrin or fructose and so I said
well hey check out the kel'thatis
they've got other stuff in there or the
ultimate daily classic and he said oh I
really don't like the sodium benzonate
um how do you have anything that you
think could be a good substitute for him
to get the Baseline 90 that doesn't have
those things in it or maybe something I
can talk to him about why he doesn't
like those ingredients
yeah we need to find out why he doesn't
like those ingredients when you have a
product that has a healthy brain and
heart pack has 215 ingredients in it
okay and so a lot of those ingredients
work shoulder to shoulder with its next
to our neighbor ingredient and you can't
just take out a piece otherwise you
won't get the results you're looking for
so we had to find out why he doesn't
like those ingredients
well he said that sodium benzonate was a
really nasty preservative according to
his research and he's was diabetic and
had afib and a bunch of that stuff until
he went keto so he's trying to stay away
from all of the the sugars
if he has diabetes or even pre-diabetes
we have a product called sweeties you
can take three of those twice a day and
that will support healthy blood sugar
levels and um if he's on medication
don't cold turkey off the medication but
as the blood sugar begins to drop he can
reduce the medication based on the
numbers okay and we deal literally with
thousands of people daily in 80
different countries with blood sugar
problems either reactive hypoglycemia or
hypoglycemia Diabetes Type 2 Diabetes
Type 1 diabetes you name it
um blood sugar problems we are World
experts at that
awesome I will bring that up to him
because he may be still trying to manage
his insulin resistance or something like
he's been doing with keto
um can you speak a little bit about
sodium benzonate as a preservative is it
is it as bad as he thinks it is or no
he's thinking of something different
no I'll have to do some research
okay
I will look into that too all right
that's all I had thank you thank you for
answering some questions thank you Genji
and that's a great question I get that
quite a bit and I I'll speak a little
bit to it so it and I've actually spoken
with
um Richard written one of our
formulators and also Steve Wallock and
we use the least amount of preservative
and absolutely possible folks if you
were to take out all preservatives
you would be ingesting mold and bacteria
and the things that are causing Havoc
within the body so do you want to add
more of those things that cause
destruction and cause digestive issues
or take something that is actually
natural
and use it as a preservative in the
smallest amounts to be able to then take
your supplements without them having a
negative reaction within the body
so they're very very picky on what
ingredients they use and everything has
a specific purpose
whether it's an essential nutrient
that's needed or one of those cofactors
that allows the body to be able to
utilize those essential nutrients to
their fullest capabilities
so just a little bit of insight on that
now let's go Dr Wallach to Anne-Marie
and Marie go ahead and unmute yourself
and welcome to daily with Doc
hello
um I have a lady who is trying to save a
tooth
apparently the tooth has been getting
infected repeatedly and is affecting her
body and she wants to know is there some
way that she the dentist told her she
has to have it removed but removing it
will hinder her from being able to wear
the partial that she
common wears
um so she's trying to see is there any
way she can save that to get rid of the
infection
um well is she getting antibiotics
foreign
it's a repeated long-term thing that's
been going on and yeah
if she has an infection she needs
antibiotics
okay okay
um
to prevent my teeth from getting
infections I use a lot of uh mouthwash
after each meal and before each meal and
during the day okay so I'm I'm trying to
kill and knock down a number of viruses
and bacteria and fungus and yeast that I
can
but we do have
you know when you have dental problems
of your Jawbone and the dental Crescent
in your in your skull
you get osteoporosis and food gets down
in there and begins to
um ferment and cause all kinds of
problems and so forth and if there's a
constant problem
um there's some other basic issue
causing this constant problem okay she
needs to get rid of all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed me some oils or
gluten so we can burn around oh so
buckwheat or sugar no carbon or drinking
the diet drinks got to go
um does she have osteoporosis
um you know she does she have diabetes
does she have how much pressure we need
to know all those things does she have
arthritis okay yes she does she's on
she's on the 90. okay good
all right but she needs to stay away
from the bad stuff so she can maximize
absorption utilization okay
let's go there he does have erosion off
the um the the jaw bone
yeah okay so she needs some vitamin D3
we have wonderful vitamin D3 she needs
to make sure she's taking enough
of the
uh MSM uh how much does she weigh
oh gosh I can't remember
okay per 100 pounds of body weight she
needs one bottle of MSM so you take a
minimum of three twice a day uh she has
been taking the MSN okay good good and
then of course
um colloidal silver if she has an
infection in there uh she can take two
droppers full of colloidal silver say uh
five or ten minutes for each meal and
five or ten minutes for bedtime and and
five minutes after she wakes up in the
morning colloidal silver okay I go
through two of those I think they're
um four ounce bottles or six times five
whatever it is four or six ounces
four ounces yeah that's what I thought I
go through two of those a month okay
and uh I have a long cheese except one
was knocked out in a fight in this in a
mall
three guys are trying to take my bags
okay but still I'm 84 years old and I
have all my own teeth don't have any
don't have any of those problems because
I use all the nutrients and I also use
the colloidal silver
thank you
all right thank you Anne-Marie for
coming on and Dr Wallach let's go right
over to Roselle and who has her hand up
for a client Rosella go ahead and unmute
yourself
hello and thank you
um I have somebody I have a couple
questions on YouTube one is from Mike uh
I'm sorry Michelle
and the good doctor tell me how to avoid
kidney stones
I have started intermittent fasting in
keto and don't want any issues
I have only one kidney due to being a
living Kidney donor
okay no wait or anything so let's just
go buy a hundred pounds please
okay the kidney stones are caused by
Calcium deficiency
kidney stones are caused by Calcium
deficiency so your body starts pulling
calcium out of the bones to maintain
blood levels of calcium
and then of course it does some silly
things and gives too much calcium out of
there and it deposits in the kidneys is
a kidney stone
and people say I don't take any calcium
supplements I don't eat bones why am I
getting kidney stones well it's because
you're not taking any calcium you're not
eating any bones because and so your
body is pulling the calcium out of your
bones to maintain healthy blood calcium
levels but it's overreacting and so
that's why you got kidney stones okay
okay thank you and then
um
I think it's me and
how do you treat DVT naturally
I'm sure how to treat what DVT
I'm not sure what that Rebecca do you
know what that is
deep vein thought thrombosis thank you I
couldn't remember oh she left out One
initial
dvtd okay
okay
um it will deep veins thrombosis I need
to make sure they're taking all 90
essential nutrients including the efas
um they can take per 100 pounds of body
weight they could take one or two efas
twice a day I take um
two of the efas
um twice a day into the if eight pluses
twice a day and um
some people might get some bleeding or
something like that you know if they get
bumped around a little bit in their job
or something
um or they wrestle or weight lifts and
stuff like that to get some bleeding and
so you want to kind of monitor what's
going on
um if you make yourself shaving and you
can't stop the bleeding during the day
if you want to cut your efas down okay
because they will
reduce
pathological blood counting but they
can't determine whether it's
pathological or is natural okay
okay all right thank you
all right and then there's one more um
Gary
says
is A1C is 6.7
he weighs 195 pounds
and he says night is six
his height is six foot one
is GFR is 4 not 49.5
so that's gum the glomular filtration
rate doctor glomerular
and that was all the information I have
okay well you give her all the bad stuff
195 pounds these two how they're burning
hard packs for months uh needs two
bottles a month in the MSM take three
breakfasts right lunch at dinner time
you also need the ultimate daily classic
tablets get two bottles of them on
Thursday take three breakfast three
dinner time those can support healthy
blood flow through blocked arteries and
and support healthy blood pressure
okay
thank you
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
so Dr Wallach we were talking about hard
tissue in the beginning and the
importance of keeping strong bones and
then we are talking about the kidneys
which is soft tissue and getting kidney
stones because it's pulling the calcium
out of the bones because there's not
enough calcium in the diet
so that just goes to prove that when you
are working on one area of Health you're
actually affecting all areas of Health
that is correct
efficiency in one it's actually
affecting
other areas of Health
which is why you have the 90 essential
nutrients that address the body as a
whole correct that's correct that's why
in the beginning we said you know we're
not going to really be pushing one
vitamin or one mineral we are pushing
the 90
and then we have we call secret sauces
which go along with individual diseases
but the secret sauces are add-ons to the
90. and so people always want to know
what's in that secret sauce well
um when we used to tell people what was
in there and they just run to the
grocery store and buy that one mineral
or two minerals and then three months
later they would die because they
weren't taking everything they were just
trying to you know if
um save a few bucks so they threw their
life away
many times Dr Wallach you do have people
that are coming to you in very very poor
health
folks don't wait until you're getting to
the almost too late
period to wake up and realize that there
is some great value in making sure that
you yourself
intentionally are paying attention to
what you are and aren't putting in your
mouth
now Dr Wallach has mentioned the Good
Foods bad foods list a few times you can
find that list on our website daily with
doc.com
and we have the Good Foods we have the
bad foods and for me
I am human you tell me I can't have
something it used to be
I would just want it more
but it's because I was nutritionally
deficient and I had those Cravings you
tell me I can't have something I just
mentally because I had some mental stuff
going on too that's what I was driven to
but folks you give your body those full
essential 90 essential nutrients and
even the brain can think better
Dr Wallach let's go to one more question
that we have and Miss Hattie go ahead
and unmute yourself you're on live with
Dr Wallach
awesome awesome
Dr Wallach I was on Facebook a few weeks
ago and I stepped into a chat and a
woman was talking about how she just
fell
and she was very concerned about it and
the other women in the chat began to
share similar experiences where they
just fell and it was like
what do you do about that the woman who
began the chat said that her doctor
wanted her to have a bone density test
but she wasn't on any medications and
she's like frantic now you stand up and
you fall for no apparent reason so what
is that what's going on and I don't have
her information I apologize well the
first thing she needs to do is get a
walker or a cane or something so she
doesn't keep
okay you just go to any pharmacy and get
a walker a little lightweight a walker
or a cane
and that way she'll reduce the numbers
of fall she has because you get a
fracture then you're in trouble you know
if you're a senior
then per 100 pounds of body weight she
needs and she may have osteoporosis of
the skull okay
um and so she is very common to fall
when you have osteoporosis of the skull
because these spinal cord gets squeezed
by the skull and all those nerves from
the neck down go to sleep and she you
know the body can't figure out what to
do so they just falls down okay that's
one possibility
so per 100 pounds of body weight one
hell of a billion heart packed per month
divided up a half she weighs 110 pounds
a half a dose of breakfast half a dose
of dinner time
then she also needs the MSM per 100
pounds of body weight one bottle of MSM
take three twice a day it's gonna help
rebuild cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrae bone makes fun of self
and
um then she also needs the collagen
peptides get a scuba that with her
morning drinks whether evening drink
that's going to help rebuild cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between invertebrate bone makes
about itself we also wanted to have a
rebound or sports drink we have the
stixers 30 sticks in a box there's no
carbonation in it but it does give you
75 more minerals and 25 more vitamins
amino acids to help maintain what's
going on in your joints and your bones
and and so forth in the brain and so on
okay and so that's kind of a place to
start and
um and you know get more information
give us a call
all right thank you Miss Hattie and Dr
Wallach you had mentioned something
about the rebound rebound and having you
know all these nutrients in it I know so
many people that
um don't drink a lot because
they don't want to have to get up and go
to the bathroom all the time well folks
many times like and you've asked you've
heard Dr willick ask how many times do
you get up tonight go the restroom
and then relating that to osteoporosis
of the skull
but if you're dehydrated
your whole body is dehydrated you're not
getting the fluids that your body needs
in order to make
blood right Dr Wallach correct and
dehydration things start to shrink they
don't function as well so rebound and
adding that to your diet is your daily
intake would be a fabulous option for
people who even don't even like to drink
water which I don't understand but there
are people out there doc
so I know that you love rebound I'm a
loving rebound I love it in the canister
the powder or even the sticks just
quickly adding it to water great flavor
and gives extra little boost of energy
plus I know I'm getting all those
minerals and nutrients that are
supportive for Healthy Living so Dr
Wallach I know you have to get going to
your next program thank you so much for
joining us here on daily with Doc and we
will see you next time hey thank you for
all you do here and your team God bless
each and every one of you and God bless
everybody out there see you later
God bless you too Dr Wallach bye for now
and if I could get my co-hosts on the
screen with me that would be greatly
appreciated folks
you are watching daily with Doc
this program is being brought to you by
dailywhitdoc.com which we are just a
handful of the many many amazing people
that are part of this Crusade with Dr
Wallach as Associates of youngevity and
people who many are certified holistic
health coaches that have gotten that
certification through the Institute of
holistic health make sure that you get
back with them or reach out to us and
get more information about this course
it's an affordable course it has a
payment plan you don't have to want to
be a health coach to get this
information the value in it can be
implemented into your own health your
own families and then of course shared
with people you know and love when the
time arises
but make sure that you are arming
yourself putting Tools in your toolbox
both
mentally as knowledge and physically
through intentional supplementation so
that you can be the best you for those
who are around you and depend on you
now I don't like to be dependent on
anybody
but the people that you see on the
screen with me right now I have grown to
become dependent in a healthy way
because I have my executive production
manager Russell and Sanchez which just
helps to she helps to organize
everything for me I used to do it in the
beginning on my own and in the beginning
it wasn't so bad but now it has become a
job that is beyond myself and I'm so
thankful to have her with me on this
journey and helping to make this all
happen for you folks we're here for you
and her assistant production manager
um AJ who is helping us get this out on
even more platforms like Rumble YouTubes
Instagram Spotify Amazon music I heart
um some of these I don't even know what
the icon stands for
um but folks
if you're watching this program let us
know that you're there put a chat put a
comment in the chat in the comments like
us subscribe to our channels and share
this information so we can all work
together to have healthier communities
and a healthier world and AJ with all of
his knowledge and experience and
technical stuff
I just thank you AJ for all that you do
as being part of this team and then we
have Marilyn who is typing frantically I
mean we got to make sure she keeps her
collagen and her glucogel and in
addition to the 90 essential nutrients
to keep those fingers limber so that she
can continue to get this information
typed into the chat for all of you who
are here live with us so thank you
Marilyn for using that amazing skill
um I used to do that myself and yeah I
got to where it was more than I could do
so I couldn't do it without you Marilyn
thank you so much for adding that to our
team and Sherry who is coming to us from
other certification programs where she
was missing the solution
that really worked and she is here as
one of our amazing coaches who is hoping
to let people in answer questions
watch the cameras and make sure that
it's a safe place for everybody to be so
thank you Sherry you add more than just
what I asked or mentioned but all of my
team and those that are not with us
today
um and those that aren't part of the
Zoom team
that are part of my critical Health news
team
and all that they do folks like I said
we are just a small handful of people
who have a passion to help others
if you were shared this program by
somebody specific get back with them and
tell them thank you
if there's nobody to think go to our
website daily
withdoc.com and send us an email let us
know that you are interested in knowing
what you can do to help yourself because
you are an empowered individual and
we're on we're on this planet
to be a resource for you
so
my name is Becca Dukes as the hostess of
this program it is my privilege and
honor thank you so much for joining us
on daily with Doc we will not be here
Thursday or Friday this week so make
sure that you go and catch some of the
replays that you have missed in the past
and we will see you next week on daily
with Doc bye for now
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign